hi guys how's it going it's ideas of Ice
and Fire here and as per tradition I'm
uploading another one my dune talk
videos because I've been uploading one
of these where I just talk after I
upload one of the big episodes so like
after Messiah I did one of these and
after the children are doing video I did
one of these so I'm doing another one um
because I had just uploaded my god
emperor of dune video this video was was
hard to do especially towards the end
because I was having some serious
problems rendering it the rendering kept
crashing it was very frustrating because
it was such a large project and I don't
know how much you guys know about video
editing but the larger the project the
more complicated everything is and so it
the more difficult it is to catch
problems and the more difficult it is
the fix problems like once something is
rendered you can't the only way to fix
the problem is to go back in and
rillette it like I mean and then
rerender it and rendering takes hours
and hours and hours and hours for this
video it took ten hours to render but
that was that was on the third go
actually so initially and I'm getting
very technical but like initially I was
using Sony an older version of Sony
Vegas that actually wasn't optimized for
the graphics card that I actually had
because I have a newer Nvidia graphics
card and the older version of Sony Vegas
didn't have GPU rendering for this
graphics card for some reason which was
weird because the previous version of
that software did but then the newer
versions didn't but now this newer newer
version that I just got did but the
first render took 40 hours well it was
would have taken 40 hours to complete
but it crashed and that was on the old
software and then I was like oh my god
tried to render it again
was having some issues again well
actually initially after that render
failed I went back in and did some more
edits because I'm like oh I can fix this
and fix that and then tried to render it
again and I was like why is this so slow
I'm just thinking in my head like why is
this moving so slow so what I did was I
time ism research I realized that my GPU
acceleration or whatever isn't on for
this program I figure out that I need to
update the software I update it and then
I cut down the rendering time from from
like 40 hours something crazy to like 10
hours so then I'm good and then start
rendering again that stops at like 81%
and that was that was like earlier today
earlier this morning when I get up in my
okay the video is gonna be done a little
bit it's frozen at 81% I'm like holy
crap some like the re-edit changed the
settings a little bit start the render
over and then I'm just a chronicle i
chronicled all of this over twitter by
the way if you follow me on twitter
you've seen the chaos that producing
this video was while getting it out was
so yeah i was talking about like how
yeah and then i tried to upload it and
then my internet went out randomly and
then I was worried that I was gonna have
some kind of processing era it was just
like a huge ordeal and the fact that it
takes so long and the file size is so
huge it end up being like an 8 gigabyte
file
there's just it increases the amount of
stuff that can go wrong
but it's out there and people seem to be
really enjoying it I'm very happy about
it I'm very excited the longest part of
the problem the long the longest part of
the process
always is research especially for God in
14 I cuz if I'm gonna be explaining the
Golden Path to people I got to make sure
that I know what the frick I'm talking
about and that I don't make any mistakes
when I'm explaining the golden path and
exactly what it is because it's not
honestly it's not that easy to pick up
on reading especially if you've only
read the book once probably not gonna
pick up on what the golden path is just
like later says in the book like you
might know what happened but I doubt you
understand it and yeah it certainly took
me several readings of God in / of doom
to fully fully grasp everything that
late so had planned for the golden path
because it's multifaceted there's a lot
going on in the golden path there's a
lot there's a lot to it so it's not just
one thing so yeah research was always
the most the longest part because I'm
reading the book over and over and again
taking notes
looking through the older books seeing
if there's stuff that I could find there
and then there's the script writing
process where I have to like figure out
okay what do I include and what do I not
include now there was of course stuff
has to be not included obviously because
it's not like this is this video what is
an hour and 37 minutes long it's like
the length of a movie and yep in even in
movies when they adapt stuff they can
couldn't put everything in so the stuff
I really wanted to focus on the meaning
of everything and I really wanted to
focus on characters and why they were
doing what they were doing and why they
were behaving the way they were behaving
like I focused on acciona and trying to
explain her
Nayla and trying to explain her and why
she acts the way she does if she's a
fanatic
Duncan Idaho how he feels just he feels
very out of place and he has he has all
these archaic sensibilities so he
naturally rejects to this type of thing
yeah and just explaining why people are
doing what they're doing when a o and
then the God in / expecially so I really
wanted to get into those characters so I
cut out some of the I guess more action
stuff like I'm aerated when the face
dancers were attacking like that Thalia
likes two attacks and stuff but I I cut
that out because I was just action stuff
I don't really need to put like a
section showing that that happened and
the ciona rebels stuff that I didn't
think matter quite as much I cut some of
that out cut a lot of it out basically
there's basically none of it cut out
some of those characters and didn't
really talk about them but the core of
the story is here what was necessary
about the story I think I left in and
then some of that some of those
cutscenes will probably end up on
patreon by the way so if you're not so
donate a dollar on patreon and then
whenever that goes up on patreon you'll
get it like if you like that's that's
the way my patreon works you donate a
dollar and you get everything but if you
donate two dollars then you get access
to the monthly livestream but yeah
dollar you get all the videos that go up
on patreon that's not on YouTube but
yeah so yeah I'd caught some stuff but I
left I made sure I kept in all the stuff
that really really matter like all the
stuff about the Golden Path I kept that
in and yeah everyone seems to really
like it and one criticism that I've
gotten a few times about my ultimate
guide to doing videos is that oh it's
more of a summary it's less of a guide
well it is a guide because if you read
the book and you come back and you watch
my video you're going to pick up things
in this video that you didn't
necessarily pick up in the book like so
it's it's when I put it all in one place
and I have this and I have and I'm
reading quotes from the book and I'm
giving you exposition on explaining
these things it is certainly a guide
it's not something I don't think it's
not something that you read while you're
reading the book it's something that you
read it's something that you watch after
you've already read the book or even
potentially even if you haven't read the
book so the videos the ultimate guide
it's like structured each one is
structured like from beginning middle to
end like narrative Lee so that even if
you haven't read the book you can come
in here and you can know the context of
everything and you can understand what's
going on it's just it's for
accessibility it's easier to follow that
way because if doing is anything
it's not easy to follow necessarily for
people just picking it up and just
reading it for the first time it's not
necessarily easy there was some other
stuff that I cut as well from this video
because I'm doing later videos on it
for instance Mulkey we know he's uncool
I've had a whole video that I've got
planned on him so he's not really in the
ultimate guide at all really but I'm
doing I'm doing a video in him so you
don't got to worry about that so I've
got I've got some stuff playing about
that because I think he is really
fascinating because he really knew the
god infra he understood the god emperor
in a way that nobody else did
even manao manao didn't even understand
the non emperor as much as mal mal key
did and because he knew the god emperor
so well he knew what his weakness was
and his weakness was he he loved he
still had love he still felt loved and
the many Jesuit even as the bidding just
ribbit of always said love is a weakness
the many Jesuit have always known this
and it was it was late to his
vulnerability and the IXY ins were able
to destroy him with the weinery
essentially or at least they were
fundamental in his destruction because
maybe it would have taken this Duncan
Idaho a bit longer to betray Leto if it
hadn't been for weinery by the way this
is my least favorite Duncan and the
entire noon series this guy is so
annoying dude you're freaking suck you
you're you're total douche and one of my
favorite parts of this entire book and I
made sure I put this entire scene in
there I made sure I narrate this entire
scene is when manao just totally just
owns Duncan Idaho intellectually
physically it just just like dunkey I
dignity is just shattered like Duncan's
just going on about I saw two girls
kissing I'm so upset
and then manao is like dude like like
gays are cool like what's wrong with you
like I'm friggin Church and then going
attacks manao like what a child like I
totally get what Leto calls him the
oldest man in the universe and the
youngest man in the universe at the same
time because it's just mentally he's
such a childlike manao is such an
evolved person I'm O'Neill was such like
a higher thinking person and I see why
he's so annoyed by duncan idaho
throughout this entire book he's just
like a little freaking duncan idaho god
this dude such a freaking jerk and you
know the last Donkin idaho was way
cooler because he was like a mint at so
that guy just just by virtue of him
being a mint at he's just cooler and
he's like pinks on like a higher level
but then this regular dog in idaho he's
just kind of like a jerk and then when
you think back to it in in the first
dune that duncan Idaho was kind of a
douche - but he gets to drone Kenny
starts like accusing the lady Jessica of
being a traitor
so maybe Duncan Idaho is just kind of
always a douche but he's I like him a
lot more in heretics at chapter house
like that duck in Idaho is way cooler
than this one this is like the this is
the sucky Duncan this is the sucky duck
in Idaho but it was fun narrating that
scene in particular and then Doug and I
know he gets all depressed after that
he's like oh but I mean wouldn't you be
feeling some type of way if someone told
you you were an older model he's like
you're just an older model that Leto
keeps rebuilding over and over again for
some reason like I am I am evolved and I
am a higher form of human you're some
you're from 3,000 years ago dude you are
so old you are trashed your genetics are
finished like get out of here and the
funny thing about it too is that manao
actually has Duncan Idaho's genes like
he's descended from at least one from
some Duncan Idaho in the past and so
acciona so it's kind of interesting that
seonah becomes mate with duncan idaho in
the end because another version of him
was her great-great something
great-grandfather so that's that's so
freakin weird and interesting and cool
that's why I love science fiction
so this video was so much fun to do just
so much fun to like revisit this book
and just reread it so many times just to
dive back into this universe it's always
fun to put together these I don't think
I'm gonna do another one that's this
long again I feel like this one needed
to be because I feel like the God in /
of doom is the most profound book in the
series in my opinion but and I felt like
it need at the hour and 40 minute like
length it's like it needed it in my
opinion so I'm glad that everyone
enjoyed it I'm looking forward to
working on heretics I need a little
break and like this video won't have any
edits in it either because like I am so
done with editing right now I don't even
want to look at my video editing
software right now I'm gonna put this
audio in there throw an image behind it
and that's kind of uploaded yeah guys
thank you guys so much for your support
it is always great to know you guys
enjoy my videos I am so thankful that
all of these doom fans from around the
world can appreciate my content whether
they start at reading dune decades ago
when it first came out or they just
started it's always amazing but it does
I will admit it always blows my mind
when I read a comment from one of you
guys saying I read dune for the first
time thirty years ago and I really loved
your ultimate guide to do in series and
I love your videos that is the most
incredible thing in the entire world to
have such longtime fans of the series
appreciate my work and it's just it's
really freaking amazing to have that
kind of acceptance for people that know
the source material so so well and have
been fans of the series for so long it's
it's actually it's actually magnificent
so just thank you guys so much and yeah
if you haven't seen ultimate guide to
gotten approved dune check that out it's
on my channel right now peace out dudes